Smart投資教室上課囉!
嗨,大家好,我是仲威。
現在大盤已經快要破五萬點了,
可是為什麼很多人的心聲跟我一樣,
覺得我的股票沒有漲呢?
臺股在創新高,
可是我的持股卻在創傷,
大盤紅通通,
只有我的打開來是綠油油這樣。
到底現在這部行情,
有沒有可能雨露均霑,
大家都漲到呢?
那到底我的持股或是觀眾朋友的持股,
是還沒有輪到,
還是它可能已經轉弱了?
所以今天呢
我們邀請到K線捕手楊周杰老師
現場幫大家解惑
中威好各位觀眾大家好
臺股在創新高
然後也都快要突破五萬點了
到底我的持股是怎麼回事
為什麼它沒動
是套牢了轉弱了
還是我看不懂行情
它還有發動的可能
OK好
那我們先把這個問題
稍微分切割開
我們是一個先看這個
指數的部分
是
好那我們說
其實我們在技術分析
有可能精確的詞
就是創高跟突破
對創高跟突破是有點距離的
對
就是說創高只是它過高了
可是突破是它真的穩定了
已經站穩
對它已經要往上走了
對
那我們這個加權指數
它其實在10月5號之前
它沒有有效的突破
它只是創高
對
所以到10月5號之後
才正式的突破
對
那所以說
當我們貴買指數在10月2號
那邊就已經開始突破了
所以說我們上個禮拜的時候
你會感覺到
中小型股開始
慢慢比較活潑了
是
對那全職股休息
就會有這個輪動的現象
所以說那就要看你當時買的股票是哪一種
如果說這個時候主流輪動是在中小型股
你就買中小型股
那當然就跟著動
我就會跟著喜氣洋洋
那如果說這個時候漲的是加權指數
那你都是漲權指股
那你的股票就不會動
就是叫做市場窄化
你就比如說有一百檔股票
假設只有十檔股票在漲
就只有十分之一
所以我們叫做窄化
就是那個市場寬度比較小
那如果說有三成甚至到四成股票都在漲
就是寬度比較夠
那你會發現我們在上個禮拜的時候
我們這個上漲的
不管是短期或中期的多方股票
其實都大概兩成多三成多
所以還是蠻窄的
可是到這個禮拜就感覺不一樣
這個短線的已經到四成了
那中長期的已經到三成
就是很明顯的漲上來
所以必須這兩個指數的表現
跟這個結構都改善了
那這樣子我們的這個散戶會比較有感
就是說這個行情真的上來了
沒錯
好 那我們來看一下土的部分
那我們看得到
這個大漲的這一天
漲了一千多點
對
好 所以這個時候什麼
才叫做有效的
這一根才叫做有效突破
就是十月五號
對 那可是上個禮拜
這個地方叫什麼
這個只是叫做創高
所以你會感覺到說
曇花一現
漲完就熄火了
所以說這一根
你才會覺得比較有感
好 那如果是中小型股呢
你會發現為什麼
上禮拜就開始有感覺
因為你看
連續漲了三四天了
對 從上禮拜大概三四五
這樣就連著漲過來
所以說它會表現得比較穩健
中小型股先漲
不過目前為止的話
都是屬於健康輪漲的過程
我覺得是OK
好 再來就是我們剛剛提到這個
所謂的這個均線多空比的概念
就是短線多方個股
你看上個禮拜
多方排列股票才28點多
那這個中長期的才20%
所以說很少
才兩層三層
可是這裡面不一樣
你看短線多方已經到40了
對 那中長期的已經到3層
所以說這個結構上就相對的很強
所以感覺我們現在整個市場趨勢
應該確實像是指數會持續創高
往這個方向走上去
所以多頭的股票也開始慢慢變多了
所以我也不用太著急
說不定我那個綠油油的
馬上就有機會翻紅了
所以接下來我們可以抱持
比較樂觀的心情
真的有可能會遍地開花
雨露均霑嗎
以目前情況看是這樣子
對我們等一下會講到
多頭看支撐這件事
之後再跟大家聊
好所以相信很多人
現在最在意或是最煩惱的
一定就是說
大盤漲了
可是我的股票沒漲
像我剛剛提到
我的還綠油油
那我這時候就要開始想了
我的到底是短期的被套牢的
還是還沒輪到我而已
我要續報
等待它蓄勢待發
蓄日東昇的那一刻
那我們在檢視一檔股票
其實要看很多指標
不管技術面從往
大概會有十多個
那我們這邊講最簡單常用的
就是說
第一個就是我們說
我先看籌碼面
那籌碼面基本上
我的習慣會看四個主要指標
就是看三大法人
然後再看融資融券
再看主力指標跟買賣加速
看這四個
這樣就可以了
簡單的
好 那如果說籌碼還集中
好 再來就是你指數在盤整
可是你的二十日線還上揚
只要具備籌碼集中
二十日線還在上揚
那這兩個股票你就不用太擔心
整理完之後
基本上會往多方前進
好 可是如果反過來
好 你的股票是籌碼分散
而且二十日線已經下完了
那你就要小心說
這個可能隨時會跌破盤整區間
對 所以要看這種情況
甚至已經做頭的
就會更危險
好 那我們來看一下
這兩個很標準的個案
剛好顛倒
好 一樣的
像聯茂
它之前是不是還在盤整
對 可是盤整過程中
二十日線
二十日線就是才有粉紅色的
對
是不是還在上揚
是
對 那這個時候
你就不用太緊張
那加上它籌碼
雖然法人有賣一些些
但是賣不多
所以這種如果不多
還可以接受
那所以它後來
還有機會往上走
好可是反過來像這一檔
好你看盤整過程中
哇這條粉紅色的二十字線
很明顯的向下了
對那隨時你要小心
這個可能會跌破
而且它籌碼非常弱
所以說就是兩個很典型的
不同的一個多一個空
可是很多人聽到這裡
可能開始又會想說
既然弱的要處理掉
那我當然希望
那把這個已經轉弱的賣掉
然後呢去往新的
比較強的標題去前進
可是有沒有可能說
現在因為股票輪動了這麼快
我才剛剛準備好要買的
結果一追
它就開始跌了
或者是我才剛把
我覺得要轉弱的賣掉了
可是誰知道
我一賣掉它就漲起來了
這是散戶潮遇到的狀況
有沒有可能就兩頭空
就是我們常常講說
書上都教我們要太弱留強
結果我把弱的賣掉
弱的就漲上去
我把強的賣掉
把強的追上去
結果它就掛了
我們說太弱留強
這件事本質上是沒有錯
只是說你應該有一些
更嚴謹的條件
那我們先講第一件事就是說
這個強勢股
那跟漲多股
其實它通常是同一件事情
對
因為強勢股一定是漲多了
沒錯
對對好
但是問題是
漲多的強勢股
它有幾個現象出現的時候
你要稍微留意一下
第一個就是
有沒有出現正乖離過大
對就是短線急漲
第二個是什麼
上漲過程中
有沒有出現加量背離
對
那如果沒有加量背離
那就OK
就是屬於價漲量增
很穩健的狀態
也不用擔心
好
再來第三個就是我們剛剛講的
上漲過程中籌碼也就是很健康
發仁還是繼續買
好 只要具備這三件事情
那強勢股還有機會
持續維持多方去漲的結構
對 所以也不用因為擔心
它已經漲了好長一段
就不敢再繼續追
其實它還是有空間的
對 好
那再來就是你剛剛提到說
有沒有怎麼避免說
我們把這個剛好顛倒
我們太多流強剛好顛倒
結果太強流弱了
那這時候就要回到
我們這個在上課
或者我們在上課訂閱分享會
會常常講的一些技術分析的濾網
像我在個人在做這個過濾的時候
我大概會有十幾個技術分析工具
對 那是這樣子整個跑一輪下來
你就可以幫股票打分數
那通常股票如果能夠具備8分以上
那基本上是安全的
對 那如果你要去做加碼的動作
至少要8.5分甚至9分
這種股票才能夠買
對 所以說不是說你看到一檔股票
或聽到一個消息
或者是看那個新聞
或者是出一個財報
你就衝進去了
這樣是很危險的
簡單講一下
就是有幾個主要的工具
第一個就是
我們講說第一個就是趨勢
就是第一個你要多頭趨勢
第二個是你不要長太多
位階不要太高
我們說長高
長多就是最大的風險
對不對
好那再來是形態
我們希望是
最好是底部形態剛剛長
再不然就是
剛剛我們講那一檔
盤整完有騎行
又要續長
好再來就是
它不要有太大的壓力
上漲過程中
前頗壓力不要太多
好再來就是
我們剛剛說的籌碼面
那最後一個很重要
就是我們要目標價
我們希望能夠透過技術面
去估算出有效的目標價
其實還有四五種方法可以估得出來
對
好 那再來就是最後一個
有突破訊號
那如果說這些每一個條件
它都拿到分數
不用滿分
就是拿到1分或0.5分
那這檔股票基本上
應該就會符合8分以上
沒錯
所以這張很重要
大家一定要記起來
很好用的工具
真的
如果你對技術分析熟悉的話
你習慣性的把這張巡點表跑一遍
可以避免掉很多地雷
有一些人可能已經套牢了
或者是有些人他的股票有獲利
甚至有些人可能還在觀望中
那現在這三種人
應該要在這樣子的情況之下
怎麼樣來操作呢
好 那我們現在先從第一種開始
就是說你買進去他就不動了
現買現套
對 現買現套
好 那這時候我覺得大家不要急著說
你就要趕快去攤平加碼幹嘛
不要 你要先確定
一樣回到我剛剛那個選股的條件
如果他還在健康的狀態
那這時候你可以續包
那等到他重新轉強
你才去做加碼
對 不要急著加碼
好 那第二種是說
很幸運的你買了
假設一百塊買進
他已經漲到一百二十塊了
你也不用說急著賣掉
你可以透過技術面去估算
他的漲幅滿足空間
或者是說去設定
所謂的移動式停利
比如說你可以看五日線
看KD指標等等的
那這些訊號出現
你再去做調解就好了
你也不用說漲多了
就急著想要賣掉
好 那如果空手的人
投資人不要說
那之前一直有孔高症
就是指數一直漲
3萬 4萬 5萬
你是不是都不敢追
很簡單
這時候你採取所謂的漸進式加碼
你不要說因為今天
我們衝1000多點上去
你就all in了
你可以假設你有100萬
你可以先分成
把它拆3P
30萬
我們先佈局一點基本的
比如ETF型
四值型的
或者是一些全值股
比較安全的
你先建立一點基本部位
那到時候你要再做第二階段
那你會比較踏實一點
所以我們有這三種不同的投資人
給予大家一些參考
好 那我們在講三種人
他其實有三種不同的一個操作手法
但是有一個共通點
不要因為情緒太滿
就是看到大漲大跌
然後就跟著有一點衝動的去佈局
這樣子是大忌
所以不管你是看到
你自己是屬於
現在套牢中的
或者是空手中的
或者是有一點點小獲利的
還是要穩住自己的情緒
然後留有自己操作的SOP
是最安全的
好 最後我們想幫大家再加問一題
其實現在指數已經近五萬了
感覺隨時都有突破的可能性
老師到底要建議怎麼操作
對啊 怎麼操作
OK 好 那我們說
第一個就是說
一樣的概念就是說
我們現在還是回到說
你原本是中低持股的人
好 那你不要說因為指數創新高了
那你就急著要
好像趕快怕這個高鐵沒有趕上車
趕快要撞抽門要衝進去
你還是可以確定說
你的個股是不是真的有效突破之後
你再去做加碼的動作
這是第一個
那第二個事情是說
我還是希望大家能夠分批
採取分批
不要說你一次就急著all in
那要預留說
比如說可能短線漲上去
三五天後馬上越過熱有拉回
那這時候我們還有加碼的機會
至少你手上還有一點資金
對 還有資金
那再來就是說
我們在多頭高檔的時候
第一個就是說不要去拆高點
我們常講說多頭看支撐不看壓力
空頭看壓力不看支撐
所以說只要現在往上
在前進過程當中
那支撐沒有跌破
它就是多頭
雖然說我們現在其實在上漲過程中
坦白講有加量背離
稍微 但是不嚴重 對
所以說它還是在多頭
那我們現在如果以我們剛剛講的
這個目前指數的長紅K棒
二分之一去看的話
大概最短最短的支撐是在49250
所以最短這個地方
即使回撤到這個地方
都還在可接受範圍
都還算很強
那甚至說
稍微再回到一點點五日線
我覺得的話
還在可以接受範圍
所以不是說看二十日線
那已經是最低的
那個有點慢了
如果你是
那也會有點太弱了一點點
不要回到那麼多
回到那麼多會比較有點辛苦
好 那再來就是說
我們在這個多頭
我們說多頭做多
空頭做空
盤整不要做
就是說我們要順勢操作
所以多頭的時候
我們在做多的過程當中
你可以少量經營
你甚至保守的你可以觀望
你就看戲
但是你心情要平靜
那你也可以持股中高水位
也沒關係
因為你之前買了
那去做加碼
但是有一件事千萬不要做
就是放空
你不要說因為它漲了五萬多點
漲到五萬點了
看它不順眼
然後就去空它
我就不信它可以破五萬
我要來加空
不要做這種事
太恐怖
因為我們常常講說順勢操作
所以說多頭做多
空頭做空
盤整不要做
那現在是這樣
指數是多頭
雖然我們臺股是真的全世界大概最強的
那還是要面對這個真的發生的事情
是這個很恭喜大家
然後你還是要做多為主這樣子
對恭喜大家一起見證了臺股的
對對見證這個不可思議
沒錯真的是不可思議
好了那今天我們來幫大家畫四個重點
第一就是指數創高
其實不代表雨露均霑
每一個個股都會漲
你還是要先看這個多頭股票的比例
是不是有增加
第二就是套牢股
你要從20日線
還有籌碼的集中度來看
它的這個結構
再來第三呢
就是建立股票的評分標準
最後呢
就是套牢啊
獲利空手
不管你現在處於哪一個階段
分批操作都是最重要的
如果今天
老師跟我們講解了
蠻多好用的工具跟實用方法
可是如果我們的觀眾朋友
想要學得更完整的話
聽說老師第四季
還有一個更深入
更進階的課程嗎
是
好那因為我們這樣這樣
像在做這個影片
因為影片是很短
十幾分鐘而已
所以其實多數只能聊一些觀念
跟一點點的技術分析
如果大家想要更精進的話
就可以來參考我們這個
技術分析課程
我們在第四季有三堂課
在十月份講的是這個
主力離場策略
就是你可以跟著主力一起跑掉
你怎麼判斷說
主力在高檔跑掉了
我們跟他一起跑
對
好 第二個是
停利跟停損的策略
大家很多人都只會買股票
但是不知道怎麼賣股票
所以這堂課很重要
那第三堂課就在講
我個人很多選股的秘方
小撇步
這個才是最值錢的
對 這堂課會再跟各位說
但我們這個只是簡易的說明
那我們等一下會
把完成的課程架構跟大綱
放在我們的影片下面
大家可以參考
沒問題
所以如果想要更瞭解
老師的投資方法
可以點擊下方的連結
瞭解一下Q4
我們K線補手
楊中線老師
智盛班的課程資訊
那我們今天非常感謝
楊中憲老師的分享
謝謝老師
謝謝
好 那我是政威
我們Smart投資教室下課囉
下次再見
大家拜拜